[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants alors nounours tu ne
dis pas bon soir tu es dans la lune oh
excusez moi pas trop j'étais en train de
penser à nicolas pimprenelle nous irons
bientôt les voir nounours j'ai pu je
descendis de voir tous mes amis de la
roulotte ils m'attendent patron ils sont
tellement gentils avec moi dépêche-toi
chiffon ce bon les seuls les robots
bobos
bonsoir les enfants
bonsoir amis bonsoir dada et juilletà au
excusez moi ce soir je suis un peu dans
la lune juilletà elle aime la lune elle
sort le soir quand la lune brille et u 6
kg à la ligue oui dit le no pépites à
toi qui connaît toujours de belles
histoires la ligne c'est une belle dame
qui ne sort que la nuit et qui voyagent
dans le ciel la lune est un astre pepita
qui brille la nuit parce que le soleil
l'éclair c'est trop compliqué ce que tu
dis nous moi je préfère la lune de [ __ ]
merci quand on échoue merci l'une
blanche jours mais franches l'une par
l'eau dévale lune rouge le vent bourges
dénonce nicolas et pimprenelle ils ne
sont pas dans la lune non ils sont dans
leur maison bien au chaud moi j'ai pas
souvent et moi alors les chers petits
eh bien puisque nous pensons tous à eux
le marchand de sable alors chanté une
chanson oui
la chanson à la lune oui
écoutez
avoue pas trop
oh
lorsque nounours ah bien tout est un et
qu'enfin il rejoint
lorsqu'il remonte sa grande échelle que
nous partons dans le ciel
lorsque notre nuage
samba a pr neil et nicolas
à
se tourner chacun de leur côté
sur leur petit oreiller
et je me
les a songé à tous les enfants
que la lune fait
aimer
et au même moment
il y en a qui suce
or doigt d'autres qui mordent leurs
draps
la lune riz en l'air
elle aime bien les enfants
je me demande quel bon conseil est de
leur glisse à l'oreille
que leur dites r on se crée tout bas
vraiment je ne sais pas
mais moi je sais qu'à tous les petits
je dis bonne nuit
bonne
un mort
[Musique]
bordeaux bordeaux 2 à tombeau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
non
bon
on
[Musique]